we're in a period right now that genders
scholars have called the stalled gender
revolution and what this what this means
if you look at all kinds of data what
you see is in the 1970s we started to
see a rapid closing in and narrowing of
gender inequality so the gender wage gap
for example starts to go down rapidly in
the 1970s more women are flooding into
paid labor women are being promoted you
get to the 1980s progress is still being
made although it's a little bit slower
and by the time we hit the mid 1990s
change is kind of flattened out okay so
we're not things aren't getting worse
but we haven't seen a lot of progress in
the move towards gender equality lately
so we're a bit stuck and my take on that
is the reason that we're stuck is that
we haven't effectively changed work
enough to accommodate who's actually in
our workplaces today and that once we do
that we're going to see a jump start
towards the move towards more gender
equality
one thing that we know is stereotypes do
limit women's advancement but they do so
not because people necessarily have
explicit stereotypes about men versus
women but that they have more
unconscious or implicit kind of
associations about what men are like and
what women are like and those implicit
associations then affect how we see
someone's performance how we judge their
behavior and can create sort of slight
differences in the ways that we then
evaluate men and women in the workplace
so these unconscious and explicit biases
I think are one of the biggest barriers
that we're still up against today when
we think about how we can move more
women into leadership often we have to
narrow of a conception of leaders
leaders are these you know autocratic
kind of you know - risk-taking sort of
people and our stereotypes about leaders
overlap with our stereotypes about men
such that men often look naturally more
leader like to us but if we brought in
the stereotypes of leadership that
creates a more expansive view of
leadership and one in which women are
likely to be seen as more successful so
if stereotypes are causing us to see
some people is more talented than they
are and other people is less talented
they are it's interfering with the goal
of being truly meritocratic and is
blocking innovation
what ways can we introduce policies and
procedures and tools into the workplace
that caused people once stereotypes
creep into their head to be aware of
that and stop and move beyond the
stereotype so the goal is rather than
relying on some stereotype about how men
and women are we would instead have some
sort of procedure in place that would
allow us to more effectively evaluate
the true talents and abilities of people
and therefore block the effects of bias
on their judgments we have to help
people first see biases so I do a lot of
work with I'm teaching people about the
way that stereotypes work because until
you see how stereotypes work you're not
going to be aware of how it could be
affecting your judgment and I should
just add just to be clear here is that
these stereotypes affect all of our
judgments women as well as men's we see
that very clearly you'd rarely find that
you know a situation where men are a lot
more bias than women these these are an
unconscious stereotypes we have to help
people see them first so that seeing
black bias is kind of key one of the
things that's been really encouraging to
me in this work is how many really
well-intentioned people there are out
there men and women who you know want to
get beyond bias so the question is can
we help them do that so what I've been
doing is working with a lot of different
companies to help them create tools and
so we have some ideas about the kinds of
things that work in general so for
example we know that when people have
clear criteria for say a promotion
decision that's very clearly articulated
and they read and study that criteria
before they evaluate job applicants
stereotypes are much less likely to
affect their judgments one thing that we
noticed that when people are making
decisions is sometimes the criteria they
use to judge people will shift around
depending upon whether they're
evaluating a woman or a man so a great
example that I that comes from
psychology shows that when people were
evaluating psychology faculty they were
way more likely to say well I would need
to see if she was a good teacher before
I could hire her
but that criteria hadn't been raised
when they were evaluating a man so it's
a perfectly legitimate criteria right
you would want a professor to be a good
teacher
but it was being applied much more
heavily to women than to men so one of
our tools is for someone in the group to
be noticing when new criteria are being
raised and to say something like if
we're going to consider teaching I think
we should go back and consider that for
all of the candidates so that we're
using the same criteria that two blocks
the use of stereotypes so there's a
variety of kinds of things like that
that we can do to not eliminate the
unconscious stereotypes from that are
happening in our head but to block their
negative effects and to be sure that
we're evaluating people by criteria and
not by stereotypes imagine a company
wants to say do more do better on its
diversity and inclusion indicators and
the CEO comes out and says this is one
of our main priorities and we're really
going to work hard on this and that's
great to have that kind of support from
the top is essential but what we find is
that support from the top kind of
trickles down and once you know it's
affecting sort of managers at kind of
higher levels but once it gets to kind
of the mid level of the organization it
often gets stuck so we've got you know
this CEO supporting change at the top
you've got people at the bottom that are
agitating for change but you get to that
middle level and that's what we call the
frozen middle it's a place where
organizational change often gets stuck
especially in diversity and inclusion
and so our goal in working on these
projects is to really try to work at
that frozen middle that is to develop
these tools to block bias by working
directly with people managers and by
working directly with people managers
what we're hoping to do is enlisting
them and the support of creating the
tools helps create buy-in at that level
where change otherwise gets stuck
there's something that's actually really
quite easy to do and that is we can
share the accomplishments of other women
in our networks at work one thing that
we know is that stereotypes cause women
to be seen as less competent than they
actually are and that's what limits
women's advancement women can't fix this
problem themselves right you can't as a
woman you know if people aren't noticing
your accomplishments you can't just say
I'm brilliant
for example there'll be all kinds of
backlash directed at you but one thing
that we can do is tout other women's
accomplishments so I think being very
mindful of giving attention to the
accomplishments of women in the
organization is hugely important so
individuals can do this organizations as
well I think you know announcing through
Department newsletters and things like
that the accomplishments of their women
employees are crucially important for
raising those women's status and fahrt
starting to fracture the stereotypes
that we have that are leading us to
cause us to see women as less competent
than they are